y
[Música]
donald trump pasó a la historia como el
primer ex mandatario de eeuu en
sobrevivir dos veces a un juicio
político a pesar de la toma del
capitolio del 6 de enero por parte de
sus seguidores que se saldó con siete
muertes el senado lo absolvió solo siete
republicanos votaron a favor de condenar
elecciones autonómicas en cataluña
abrieron las mesas electorales y 55
millones de personas están llamadas a
votar por los 135 diputados del
parlamento del que saldrá el próximo
presidente del gobierno pero con medidas
especiales por la pandemia tenemos
informes desde barcelona-
también hay elecciones parlamentarias en
kosovo el país de 19 millones de
habitantes espera la victoria de un
partido anti establishment lo que
complica los esfuerzos occidentales para
resolver una disputa territorial de
décadas con serbia que no reconoce la
independencia de los kosovares
una feliz mañana de domingo mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24
donald trump quedó absuelto de incitar a
la violencia contra el capitolio
estadounidense el pasado 6 de enero un
hecho que cobró la vida de siete
personas con una votación de 57 43 el
senado no logró reunir los 67 votos
necesarios para declarar culpable al ex
mandatario sólo 7 republicanos votaron
en su contra trump en celebró la
decisión condenó el juicio y anunció el
regreso de su movimiento
por su parte del presidente joe biden
dijo que el resultado muestra que la
democracia es frágil
andrés meza muñoz tiene los detalles djs
absuelto por segunda vez el senado
estadounidense no pudo condenar a donald
trump por incitar a la violencia contra
el capitolio el pasado 6 de enero el ex
presidente celebró su decisión y condenó
el proceso al que fue sometido es un
triste comentario sobre nuestros tiempos
que un partido político en eeuu tenga un
pase libre para denigrar el estado de
derecho difamar a las fuerzas del orden
animar a las multitudes disculpar a los
alborotadores y transformar la justicia
herramienta de venganza política sólo 7
republicanos votaron en contra de trump
y aunque es la cifra más alta de
legisladores que han votado para
condenar a un presidente de su propio
partido en un juicio político el número
fue insuficiente ya que necesitaban el
apoyo de 17 de ellos y así completar los
67 votos con los que lo declararían
culpable un resultado que se había
previsto en el 7 lo que vimos en este
senado hoy fue un cobarde grupo de
republicanos que aparentemente no tienen
opciones porque tenían miedo de defender
su trabajo respetar la institución en la
que sirven
institución ser a pesar de haber votado
para absolverlo el líder de la minoría
republicana en el senado no restó culpas
al ex presidente
no hay ninguna duda de que el presidente
trump es práctica y moralmente
responsable de provocar los
acontecimientos de ese día
pero rockin devils
tavera
no hay duda al respecto las personas que
irrumpieron en este edificio creyeron
que estaban actuando según los deseos e
instrucciones de su presidente
trump es el primer expresidente en
enfrentar un impeachment después de
finalizar su mandato el objetivo del
juicio político era evitar que volviera
a postularse pero mcconnell dijo que
trump no se ha salido con la suya
sugiriendo que podría enfrentar un
proceso penal
cambiamos de tema los ciudadanos
catalanes comenzaron a votar en sus
elecciones parlamentarias regionales por
la pandemia aumentaron los centros de
sufragio pero unos 33.000 jurados
presentaron alegaciones para no estar en
las mesas argumentando el peligro de
coronavirus vamos a barcelona para más
detalles con nuestra corresponsal ellis
gas en el buen día para usted el iiss
hay más de 2700 colegios electorales
como inició la jornada en medio de las
restricciones sanitarias y se prevé
abstención o por esa misma causa
pues si angela son unas elecciones
peculiares insólitas ya que por miedo a
esta pandemia pues primero se dispara el
voto por correo de 265 mil personas ya
votaron por adelantado lo que supone el
triple comparado con los últimos
comicios y segundo pues para la gente
que vota hoy presencialmente se
ampliaron los centros de votación es
incluso en lugares peculiares como aquí
un mercado municipal pero hay también
fuertes medidas sanitarias el fuego es
reducido la gente tiene que hacer cola
de fuego hay protecciones integrales
para los miembros de la mesa y se
recomiendan franjas horarias por la
mañana por ejemplo para las personas
mayores y por la tarde a última hora
sería para la gente que tiene cobit que
es positiva y para los casos contactos
pero queda por ver si todas estas
medidas serán suficientes para frenar la
fuerte abstención que prevé en todos los
sondeos
entretanto ellis la causa
independentista sigue estando en el
centro de la atención como se perfilan
las alianzas entre los distintos
partidos entre partidarios y detractores
del independentismo
pues los sondeos dan casi un triple
empate en la cabeza así que todo queda
va a poder esta noche él podría llegar
por e-mail el candidato socialista que
es el ex ministro de sanidad española el
que gestionó en la pandemia del gobi 19
en el país pero también podrían llegar
en cabeza en los dos partidos
independentistas jones por cataluña y
esquerra republicana que gobiernan
actualmente cataluña pues estos partidos
independentistas que probablemente
podrían llegar a sumar 68 escaños que es
la mayoría absoluta y así volver a
gobernar pero los expertos avisan de que
podría haber otra alianza de partidos de
la izquierda si la izquierda
independentista llega primero entonces
podrían pactar con otros partidos esta
vez no independentistas el no veremos
esta noche es seguramente a altas horas
de la noche
ellis gracias a usted y este domingo con
su voz celebra elecciones legislativas
tras haber vivido la caída de dos
gobiernos en 2020 los sondeos dan como
principal favorito a nuestra nación
lista de izquierda albin kurti quien
ganó las elecciones de 2019 y fue
reprobado 51 días después se tras una
moción de censura en su contra un
resultado a favor de alguien complicaría
las cosas en el conflicto con serbia
respaldada por rusia que no reconoce la
independencia kosovar ya abrieron los
más de 2.800 colegios electorales y
serán elegidos 120 diputados entre más
de 1.000 candidatos
[Música]
inestabilidad política 50% de paro
juvenil y 5 elecciones en 10 años estas
son algunas de las cuestiones que
marcarán las elecciones de kosovo este
domingo los ciudadanos elegirán su nuevo
parlamento entre un total de 28 partidos
los sondeos auguran una holgada victoria
para el partido autodeterminación
liderado por albin kurti un
ultranacionalista de izquierda que ya
ganó las elecciones en 2019 pero su
gobierno tan solo duró 51 días tras una
moción de censura bajo el argumento de
mala gestión de la pandemia y la falta
de diálogo con serbia
[Aplausos]
queridos los ciudadanos de la república
de kosovo después de diez días de una
increíble campaña electoral durante un
período inusual después de miles de
kilómetros recorridos y cientos de
reuniones ustedes en todos los rincones
de kosovo el momento de los cambios
nunca ha estado más cerca
cómo
el segundo mejor situado según las
encuestas es el partido democrático de
kosovo que ostentó el poder hasta la
victoria de autodeterminación el último
partido de gobierno la liga democrática
de kosovo podría quedar en tercera
posición muchos ciudadanos ven a estos
partidos como representantes de la vieja
política que llenó al país de corrupción
y sacó a kurt y del gobierno con
diversas manipulaciones
durante los últimos 20 años hasta ahora
los mecanismos para limpiar la
corrupción no han sido eficientes y
ahora ha llegado el momento de hacer una
limpieza adecuada aquellos partidos
políticos que no basen su programa en
hechos profesionalidad y sinceridad
perderán los primeros resultados
oficiales se esperan unas horas después
del cierre de las votaciones a las siete
de la tarde el ganador tendrá el difícil
reto de estabilizar el país más pobre de
los balcanes occidentales
en américa latina llegaron a venezuela
100.000 dosis de la vacuna rusa contra
el coronavirus sputnik vi el presidente
nicolás maduro anunció que el
medicamento será primero aplicado al
personal de salud durante meses el
gobierno ha dicho que el país recibirá
10 millones de dosis aunque la cifra no
ha sido confirmada
y la primera ministra de nueva zelanda y
asignada anunció un nuevo cierre por
coronavirus tras descubrir tres
contagios locales los primeros desde
enero durante tres días se mantendrá el
bloqueo en la ciudad más grande del país
auckland arden dijo que las
restricciones de nivel 3 se requieren
que todos se queden en casa excepto para
las compras y el trabajo esenciales
tres días deberían darnos suficiente
tiempo para reunir más información
llevará a cabo testigos a gran escala y
establecer si ha habido una transmisión
más amplia en la comunidad eso es lo que
creemos que exige la aproximación más
cautelosa y es lo correcto siga con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]